and he feels it there and he tries it
and I'll rock his room I'll rock his
room and drop him
bang come over the top bang drop him
that'll be your career done whistle
[Music]
right guys you know how the thing's set
we start off with a banger and the
question of the week was if you broke up
with your partner and you had to take
one thing from the yard what would it be
I didn't even see you right now with
your partner use if you woke up with
your partner and had to take one thing
from the yard what would it be Jesus
okay cool as per usual you know the
Vibes guys juicy Yeah man so imma just
just really I'm gonna just reeling more
all right say less their dad's pacemaker
charger
[Music]
foreign
a lifetime charge
it's my heart we'll talk about I
shouldn't have to charge it
facts my life the stepladder after I put
all the luxury treats and drinks on the
top shelf
your mom under Kevin Hart thing your
actual man and a thug ladder
I'm taking that washing machine door off
can you do the door
yeah of course it's a hinge bro just
break the machine don't toy with me like
literally
taking the door off I won't know what
we're doing here I wouldn't know where
to begin yeah I don't know how we're
resolving this and I don't know what
we're doing yeah I would exact word for
what I don't know where to begin facts
that's a conundrum
because you're making me feel like I
don't need a new washing machine yes do
I mean yeah me feel like I don't need
anything yeah yeah it's fine
[ __ ] you
the murder weapon
hey
what they're gonna take from the yacht
is the murder weapon bro dark
Segway I if I had if I committed such an
atrocity and confide it in you yeah and
then we had a fallen out yeah yeah and
then you just took the took the the
weapon yeah
I can't contact you about it I just have
to sit and wait facts bro sit and wait
shake that's all I could do sit wait and
Shake there's nothing you can do nothing
you can do can't bail you or anything
because ah because this is something
it's a hush hush yeah it has to be our
shopping yeah because yeah because if I
bury him block where is it where's what
where's what I'll be playing coin you
know what where's what
say it
I'm hanging up the phone
so the first dialistic could be say it
you'd hear like bear static for like
just silence for ages you just see me
breathing for like 15 seconds it's
usually say it I'm just saying like
[Music]
and then I'll just have to hang up once
I've realized I can't do anything to
hang up I know you're laughing and I'll
text you so stop the [ __ ] out
those jokes
I took his bong I don't smoke I just
hate him
wow his Nokia phone and I'm handing it
straight to the police the Nokia phone
the Trap phone yeah
I'm handing this straight to the police
wow that's my burner bro that's like
real life that's bro that is just real
life
that is top boy I'm taking his knocking
I'm handing it straight to the police
like she's in a current relationship at
the moment where her man has a burner
and if push comes to shove I'm taking
that I'm taking it and I'm taking it to
the feds
and it's got your fingerprints all over
it all over it your DNA everything all
your spit from you
how much money made today
[Laughter]
it's funny we made today
that's jokes that's hilarious all the
soap hand soap body soap and dish soap
Vex you wouldn't know where to begin
Jesus Christ this feels like this one
sounds like the perfect crime all right
gone the pillow and I'll leave the
pillowcase
that sounds like the perf I don't know
why that's worse than the washing
machine bro just yank the pillow and
just carefully place the pillowcase back
where it was and everything ironed
everything but I'll think this is like
War of the Worlds are saying like shit's
just disappeared old bro I would never
ever think it was her oh raggle you
can't you can't because because why yeah
because mines don't work yeah they don't
bro I know biology and Minds don't work
like that it's the perfect crime it's
the perfect crime because I'll be there
just um there was a a reminder there's
an old Dane Cook skit yeah there's an
old Dane Cook skit that um
bearing in mind actually before tangent
okay we'll be back to the skit in a
minute yeah yeah yeah yeah you know Dane
Cook right I know the name rings a bell
comedian like old older not old school
but like yeah older School keep talking
I'll just Google you see an employee of
the month with Jessica Simpson yes but
he's the guy he's the main guy and he's
like good he's in a film called Good
Luck Chuck yes yes
I was chatting to my boy the other day
yeah and I was for some reason I brought
up Dane Cook yeah
and he said
oh Dane Cook
he DJ'd at my freshers one time pardon
fam I was like no he never wrong Danka
yeah I just brushed yeah yeah yeah
that's actually a different human being
wrong Dane Cook get back on track with
me yeah yeah yeah Focus yeah focus focus
and he was like no no I swear he's like
a comedian or something and I was like
yeah he is and he was like yeah he did
at my freshest week in Portsmouth and I
was like no he didn't
DJ and there was a picture of dankook I
didn't investigate any further this yeah
there was a picture of Dane Cook like as
like a DJ set I think he was like yeah
he did on Refreshers like he I'm I I
believe what you're saying to me and I
believe that you believe he did yeah but
I promise you he did it and I can't
believe this is true to this David I
can't find out that that's true but
anyway there's an old Dean's uh in
regards to this pillowcase thing yes yes
yes there's an old Dane Cook skit
um bit I should say not skit uh bit in
one of his specials where it's called
the door kicker but basically he talks
about when he was younger he had an urge
to like commit crime okay he had just an
urge to commit admit crime yeah fam he
had an urge to commit crime what type of
crime yeah just non-violently like
misdemead yeah yeah okay okay
so basically yeah he picks a yard yeah
pixie out of his boy they run up
he Boots the door down dog he said the
door went flying off its hinges
he literally said it's like um do you
remember in The Matrix where they um
explode The Ting and the door they had
that slow motion
said he booted this door down and it
literally flew off his hinges into the
darkness of the corridor and that's the
adrenaline and he was gassed oh my God
and then he said like oh I don't even
have the urge to steal anything I'm just
I'm just gassed I'm pumped
um so I think he said he'd like smashed
a picture frame just to like make sure
this is what he wanted to make sure
that's sweet that makes no sense
um that's a joke so he's yeah he
literally smashed a picture frame yeah
and he was like [ __ ] it let's go so they
darted and um
he was gassed and then he said a few
weeks later he said he always used to
like lay awake at night thinking about
this family that would have come home
yeah the dad must have come in seen the
doors blown off the hinges he's like
everyone say the [ __ ] in the car yeah
stay in the car don't move in fact I was
in there ready to ramp looks around
nothing's gone that's just a picture oh
yeah and he's thinking personal yeah
this is personal it's personal yeah yeah
he's thinking this is [ __ ] person
yeah yeah yeah and he's like right I
don't know what I'm going yeah but [ __ ]
it so they get the door replaced yeah
and he said a few weeks later he went
back and booted the other door off and
dipped so the farmers come home again
he's like now what's going on and he's
running around and he's constantly must
be thinking
what did they steal yeah yeah they're
going mad yes
he's probably like changing the channel
the remote's not working properly and
he's like brother
and replace some wishes
I'm telling you now if I saw a
pillowcase randomly with no pillow and
no one else lives in this yard yeah
that's what will happen I'm thinking
someone's broken in here yeah and stolen
a pillow and I can't even confront my ex
you can't you kidnapped it would be
weeks later and I'd be like
babe random I know we're not fam okay
cool yeah
wait okay go
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] my ex calling
me for whatever
hello
yo hang on yo
yo all right oh what do you want it's
Jay in case you've deleted my number
already I remember like the last couple
days I knew it was you from the jump but
what do you want what do you want
what do you actually want
yo random literally I'm not even trying
to play foliage I've got stuff to do I
don't even want to be betting you right
now but all right I'm on a five minute
break hurry up hurry up it's random yeah
what don't judge me did you by any
chance take my pillow and leave the
pillowcase
pardon did you you thing is you know
what's actually funny you know what I
said I know what you said I heard what
you said but I'm confused as to why you
think you can call me on my lunch break
to ask me such stupid questions
I don't need the confrontation all I
need is an answer did you take the
pillow and leave the pillowcase yes or
no no
are you sure no bye
but now your gas because you actually
did that's exactly how the conversation
will go that's exactly how the
conversation will go
Rags I'll be gas you're gasp you're
literally skipping back into work gas
because you actually mission
accomplished yeah you actually did do it
and you're screaming at me by yeah
saying I'm ruining your lunch break
facts
if you broke up with your partner and
had to take one thing from the yard what
would it be the insoles in their shoes
that gave them that extra little inch
a woman sent that in of course of course
she did to give them the extra little
inch that extra little inch oh [ __ ] off
I'm not even gonna lie I want to try one
of those in songs I actually want to try
one sauce I think if you try them and
you actually see a difference I think
you're gonna get like little man
syndrome and be like oh [ __ ] I need to
wear them all the time now yeah I can't
go out without you can't go out with
that I think it's gonna [ __ ] with your
psychics yeah and like when
when you're with a girl yeah you need to
figure out a way that you can kick them
off but still keep them on and just jump
on the bed
she's got to see your height it's Syria
right heels out so you get even higher
and then just leap straight on the bed
so she can't understand
that's too funny James Oh my days right
and exchange is antidepressants with my
birth control pills
stress I'm cutting the plug from his
fridge wow wow cutting the plugs
stink he won't know what's going on
James stink he'll be opening a slamming
thought
all the family heirlooms one airpod nah
that's too much they track these airpods
thank you thank you I forgot about that
I will just text give it back
I can see you're at Starbucks
I can see your Starbucks at the freaking
beat [ __ ] Beaconsfield service
station right now I know where you're at
running give me my airport I'm coming
you can't even say it and now you're
embarrassed
is that how better you are it's actually
how better you are give me my [ __ ]
airpod a shot I would launch the airpod
I would launch the airpod and dip it'll
be one of them once away you know
attempt CSI shows where they're trying
to track command and they think they've
got man patent yeah and they just find
it in like a [ __ ] Bush somewhere yeah
that's exactly yeah fam
that's how I this that's how like
into sex violence happens because if
we've broken up yeah from my
understanding yeah yeah we've broken up
from my understanding yeah yeah yeah and
then I see that you've stolen my airpod
yeah I politely asked for it back yeah I
may remind you that you're being a bit
Petty but I don't know why you'd do that
just to annoy me to make my life
difficult I say look you don't even need
to move stay there I'll be there in 10.
cool and then you launch it because
you're such a petty little cow
I'm gonna find you I'm gonna beat you up
because I know from that psyche you
still think you're getting away with it
yeah yeah yeah right so we're constantly
thinking you're getting away with Rags
Rags I'll launch it in depth nah I'm
gonna find you're gonna beat you up
so don't beat me up it's hilarious I
don't even know why I'm gonna [ __ ]
find you I'm gonna [ __ ] beat you up
it sounds like a primary school threat
beat me up Jesus hilarious
the photo page of her passport I'm gonna
rip it out
just a photo but you would never know
until you know oh and two yeah
literally until you take it if you've
done a good enough job you won't know
until you get there and they'll be like
is this a joke
sorry
is this a joke bro literally step out
step out next
they just take your past one dash it in
a bin bro
perplexed I think I'd cry I'm 100 I
think I'd cry because I'd be so confused
and angry I wonder about what emotions
and as a fellow passenger and friend I
would
attack you like verbally attack you
because even though you have no reason
to check the page yeah yeah you're so
fixed that you did
who the [ __ ] doesn't check the page Rags
you're like who the [ __ ] does normal
people bro normal people yeah people
with crazy exes check their pages
I've got mine [ __ ] all the couch
cushions
her plunger seen as seen as the [ __ ]
loves to bring up old [ __ ]
laughs
all his razor Gods so next time he
shapes up he'll have nothing but the
blades
wow
all the left eye contact lenses oh Jesus
do they have left and right yeah oh do
they I don't actually I don't know if
they do I don't think they do I think
they do I think so when you put it in
the little yeah I think there is I think
to be fair some because people have
different yeah [ __ ] in their eyes in
it yeah because I think I'm like minus
one minus 1.25 like that I swear yeah I
know I'm Different on both
um this one my right one's worse oh is
it one million sent my right ones worse
but it's not bad enough for them to do
something about it okay it's still 20
20. but it's if I close my eyes it's
strange yeah
it's a strange world when you look at it
yeah yeah his inhaler attempted murder
yeah that's not on I'm not taking
anything but every night I'm going back
to hers I'm putting a new lock on the
gates
hmm
see I'm not taking anything but every
night I'm going back to hers I'm putting
new locks on the gate
successive that's more effort for you
than it is every night every night I'm
paying for and installing new locks
chill out bro I like a lot I mean for
the first maybe I would probably do it
maybe twice two times in one week just
to [ __ ] with her and that's what I'm
done I can't see myself doing anything
just that I'm done remember my girl I
just want her back
oh
my girl dot dot dot I just want her back
that's [ __ ] funny oh he's in his
Fields I just want her back I just want
her back oh bro this one this one will
send me loopy all the Tupperware Lids I
promise you that will send me that will
send me the movie that's that's actually
the Perfect Crime that is the Perfect
Crime I think to be fair what I would do
is if they had a set
if they had like a specific set of
Tupperware yeah I would take all the
lids and replace them with slightly
bigger lids
same color same design
slight bigger Lids that would have
because everyone has those like that the
normal you know the normal top where
they're getting like markets or whatever
you get fast food from anything
everyone's got that normal type and all
the lids are always different bro
they've I've definitely got like
hundreds of the actual um tupperware's
but 75 different lids and it infuriates
me bro when you're trying to find the
right one to package it infuriates I'm
buying slightly bigger Lids so every
time especially you know those clicky
ones
I would launch my food James I will
launch my food in the air
I'll go around there to visit you see
beckling film on top of Lids I would
laugh
just open the face that was me she's
going through turmoil oh that's stress
all right I've got a few more all right
so let's he's he's dear manga collection
posters and all the figurines no bro
that's all it is everything gone
I lock all the windows in the house and
take the keys that's that that's like
that was that was sent me into like
Suicidal Thoughts
because I feel trapped in my own house I
need air I need air and I can't find it
unless I open the main door
in bed July no no no no no you just toss
in the cover I'll be living oh [ __ ]
I'll be right in the handle
Joe's feet on the window
I do what it takes
I'm gonna take the audacity then break
the light in the fridge
oh [ __ ] sake team a couple more swap
the black hair dye with bleach he uses
it on his head and beard weakly
ow me in it allow me in it you know
actually one thing I might take now I'm
thinking about it the microwave plate oh
yeah
so I put that on our story yeah yeah
someone put that microwave plate that is
that was something brutal that's brutal
James
that was semi-crazy the microwave plate
is brutal and the last one their savings
account for the trauma because I might
say well drapes it all just drapes in
money now for the trauma I don't know I
think I'd rather lose money than lose my
microwave plate yeah Farm or my uh like
the door to my [ __ ] washing machine
that one would send me crazy about Woods
because you can't
who are you explaining that to
who are you explaining one million and
then when you buy a new washing machine
and they install it and they offer to
take the old one they're gonna be like
I'm not I'm not answering your questions
I'm not answering your questions just
take it and leave I'm not entertaining
this [ __ ] why do you think I've
ordered a new yeah why do you think I
need a new washing machine and then some
smart ass will be like oh you know you
can just get a new door right
yeah get get my [ __ ] yourself
screamed like yeah ow get ow
I know exactly what you mean oh Jesus
but yeah that was it that was the
question of the weekend all right guys
well welcome back guys happy Monday you
may or may not have noticed that the
production value has gone a little bit
up the production value's gone a little
bit
it's skyrocketing now we're doing
different we're different and we're
living different
different facts um so guys welcome back
to the show this is episode two three
one yeah I think
um we've officially moved down to London
we have
um and it feels good feels great it
feels yeah it feels pretty good it feels
expensive but it feels good and um
shit's about to start changing over here
um at shits and geek Studios yeah man um
but obviously guys what we need you to
do real quick is just pause the episode
right now and head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
it's gonna cost you a measly listen just
breathe it in a measly three pound a
month 10 10 a day you need to run the P
to SMG and in return guys we will give
you official cult baby status facts you
will be part of the sng cult in which we
indoctrinate youths the elderly we have
breeding grounds we wear white robes all
the time everyone's skin is oiled to
Perfection low in glistening and then
you just went like you just clap cheeks
on a whim oh
you clap cheeks on a whim just because
it's Wednesday just literally because
it's Wednesday afternoon yeah and you
just start I need a little yeah
I might got a sweet tooth yeah yeah and
then cheeks just appear
it's Heaven it's basically Heaven is
whatever you can think of it just
appears patreon for the for the cult
babies is basically Heaven it's Heaven
you heard it here first
um and also guys what you're gonna get
there is three years worth of bonus
content from your boys we've been on
over there for a long time now I've been
recording stuff that never met the
public view so and you get a bonus
episode every single Thursday guys okay
so patreon.com shits and gigs binge your
way
to Heaven [ __ ] binge your way to heaven
guys if you are listening on any of the
audio platforms Spotify Apple podcasts
um skeeza or whatever they call them
these days these are these eyes I think
it's these are um I prefer Giza
um
please for love of God give us a nice
review what was that God yeah
let's go past that what was that
what's that I love God
I could literally feel your eyes burning
inside of my head
um yeah please for the love of God yeah
give us a nice Review Guys Five Stars is
preferable but whatever you say just say
it with your chest so if it's a one star
please keep it to yourself but if you
have to express yourself and just want
to start by all means share the love
guys and it it means the word to us and
it allows us to spread the culty
messages
Nationwide internationally you know what
it is
um and then for you guys if you're on
YouTube you may notice that we're just
skyrocketing now and the subs are up up
up so please be part of that subscribe
to the channel again help us through it
and without guys any further Ado I'm
going to turn you over to my boy Fire
Lord Forex he's going to hit you with a
Peng little fun fact of the day foohead
please what's going on this one is wild
bro what's going on in the world many a
man sent this to me swear wild oh wait
can I guess yeah
um they send it to us as well as me
they'll probably send it to you as well
it's about someone leaving someone
yes okay I just read the title I have no
idea what it's about because I knew
something was and now it wasn't going to
be coming from me okay cool what's
coming for you facts though facts facts
yeah woman shocked after husband left
her for her daughter to start a family
once she turned 18.
so
basically stepdad
saw that their daughter was almost ripe
yeah almost couldn't situated yeah yeah
and said I'm gonna lock it early early
and just start messing with her head a
little bit so we're gonna patent a
little family so I'm assuming he's
misses old let me let me know she
doesn't want use let me read it a woman
shares her disgust after her ex-husband
started a family with her daughter
Tiffany felt like all her dreams had
come true when she met mark this is in
quotes my life felt perfect in 2010 I
had a son with my husband my life was
then complete I had two kids a great
husband a house car nice job life was
great the 40 year old American woman
wrote on Reddit
he told me that how sorry he told me
that how he was now in a relationship
with my daughter and I'm what he told me
that he was now in a relationship with
my daughter sorry and was leaving me for
her an emotional Tiffany recounted I
couldn't believe this I couldn't process
it I felt crushed angry disgusted mad
everything you would feel my now
ex-husband never gave me creepy Vibes
but if he got with my daughter but he
got with my daughter when she was 18.
four years later Tiffany learned through
a family member that her ex-husband and
daughter now have two kids together
mad two kids together
so she just locked them both off for
four years
and then she heard for the Grapevine
they'd just been breeding you've got
grandkids you've got grandkids with your
ex
or obviously with your daughter yep yeah
you know what I mean it's it's just it's
just perplexed me bro I couldn't oh my
God
that's such an emotional L I don't know
how to stomach it
it's just just it's just map because
like you said before I read it out like
he must have clock she was 17 thinking
yum I'm having that in a year's time yum
I need to figure out the name of
Targaryen thing
yeah shut the [ __ ] up
exactly on a Damon Targaryen team
because
he prayed her
he pre veneres like you're banging
regardless of whether we're related or
not yeah yeah you're physically banging
I'm having you yeah yeah and I need to
groom it because you don't seem down now
now but give it a year give it a year
yeah and we could see what's about
tiptoeing for the next 365 and by the
time we land there by the time you're 18
you're going to be good to go you're
going to be good to go You're Gonna Want
me um
but at the same time he has to slowly
take steps to remove himself from his
misses I.E the girl's mom yeah yeah and
it's like how how does one man plot and
scheme that do you know what I mean that
takes he's jobless time bro time and
effort yeah because if he if it doesn't
Pat and he loses everything he loses it
all and he's on the shade bar for the
rest of his life he's on shaper now yeah
but it's like yeah yeah if you go
through all of that and lose both you
I don't know it's like you're
blacklisted for some reason do you know
what I mean like like yeah I tried to
yeah you might as well go pen you might
as well go ahead I I was in a happy
marriage I basically raised
um this girl thought she was banging
tried to move to her she wasn't on it
obviously obviously and um then my wife
found out and and left me so now I'm on
the streets and then you can't turn to
anyone with that you can never you can
never bro what's wrong with you they're
literally what is wrong with you that's
insane
um but yeah so he was like
yum yeah bro yeah yeah I'm having that
I'm a groom it let me plant some stuff
in the head to make her think that I'm
the [ __ ]
where do they live bro bro because it
can't be a scene no no no no it must be
a village somewhere off ends in
Shropshire ends brother the Wi-Fi is
three bars offense offense yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
insane two kids James
and she just started this off from since
she was 18. and I said I'm breeding you
so just be prepared
oh this is this sounds like um what do
you call it what was that what was that
documentary we watched with the weird
little cult
no sweet pray no no no no sweet prayer
band stop praying obey or something like
that Something Something Sweet Paradise
I know exactly what you're talking about
but I can't remember what it's called or
is it stay sweet prayer
look he looked like a devil oh he did
and he had yeah he looked like
slither.io yeah oh and he had that bed
just raised in his room and he's
fighting yeah he used to make all the
wives watch where he just clap clapping
younger's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yucky
oh yeah mandamar crazy sometimes a
little bit of power literally power
drives them insane yeah
100 everyone loves a bit of power but to
an extent yeah I mean some people take
it too far and they always think they
can get away with it especially when it
comes to add in religion into that yeah
because that's the definition of a like
I'm pretty sure that is like the
scientific definition of uh so like
being a sociopath oh [ __ ] is that you
you genuinely believe that like you can
get away with anything like an Amber
hurting like you believe
and get away with it yeah that's exactly
what you can lie in line no one's ever
gonna catch you nah man nah that's
that's that's mad but yeah that's one of
the maddest things I've read I can't
believe that actually happened that
I bet I reckon I reckon in certain parts
of the world like I reckon
South South America not like South
America like the southern parts of the
USA Southern parts of North America yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah before anyone starts
getting offended
the force of argentinians are in my DMs
like what are you on about
and I'm like yes your culture
jokes
um yeah so I reckon like this the
southern parts of the USA yeah just them
yeah what yeah I reckon stuff like that
goes down I reckon some uncles and
stepdads and stuff like that are just
moving up that morning yeah yeah it
wouldn't surprise because like we say or
like we've said and like we've seen on
all these documentaries and stuff it
always happens in these kind of rural
areas with all the like especially when
they bring religion into it I'm yet to
see
touch when I never see it I'm yet to see
this kind of thing happen like this
sweet pray obey whatever it's called but
happened with Muslims I'm yet to see
anything like that that's because they
don't document that
right I hit the main street bro I'm yet
to see it because it's always
Christianity always yeah because yeah
Christian is a macarita that's why they
just let you film whatever
not
you can't even stepped foot in this
thing yeah
obviously not do you know what I'm doing
in there
I've got 19 wives I've got a raised bed
and I just clap younger's I've got all
these things maybe you're not having a
film career no never yeah Chris
Christians are deluded yeah yeah run it
yeah run it it's all in the Name of
Christ run it yeah yeah the Muslims only
let you see the protest
um yeah they really see protests on the
road especially when they're educating
man in fact there's a guy on Tick Tock
some white Muslim brother and Tick Tock
okay he loves debating people in the
street okay he loves debating people in
the street he always circles them as
well yeah yeah it's it's long but people
no one with any kind of knowledge of
anything comes to him with anything they
just start throwing words around it like
extremists yeah they think they can run
up and say the word extremist yeah and
get away with it yeah
it never passes it never ever patterns
yeah that's wild man that's very very
wild guys girls
let's take a quick break real quick pay
some bills keep the lights on in the new
studio
um lots of lots there's a lot more
lights in here a lot more so guys real
quick going to shed some love to our
boys and girls over at manscaped real
quick guys and it is the spooky season
have you ever tried to trim your balls
and it turned into a Freddy Krueger film
oh my god well luckily
man skipped us here to save the day and
make sure you're feeling your best in
your costume [ __ ] unlock your
confidence with the performance package
of 4.0 inside you'll find the Holy Grail
of Men's Grooming items they've made it
easy for you to upgrade your grooming
routine it's a full moon out and the
Werewolf in your pants is howling
brother
[Music]
um right guys it's time to tackle the
problem with the lawnmower 4.0 guys so
by now you already know what you need to
do head on over to manscaped.com the
code you need to use is sng Sierra
November golf sng is the code and
masgate.com is going to give you 20 off
plus free shipping worldwide guys
let's get back to the episode yes sir
um right I've got a little random topic
I was watching football the other day
and I think it was funny enough it was
West Ham I think it was West Ham versus
Bournemouth I could be wrong
um and obviously everyone knows that in
football and in any sport like it's the
players on the field that count but the
one person that people tend to somewhat
forget or forget that is very important
the power of the referee oh the power of
the referee so
um for those I don't know you know what
VA or VAR is video assistant referee but
for those that don't know VAR is
um a video assistant referee that's what
is actually um that's the acronym but
it's uh when um the on-field referee
can't make a decision from a certain
situation so they ask the people behind
the scenes to have a look on the camera
to see whether it's a file or not to
give a yellow card or not Etc if the
people behind the scenes can't deal with
it then they say they they speak to my
man in his earpiece say uh you man a
referee you have to deal with it yeah
yeah I'm not involved yeah deal with it
yeah so I was watching I think it was
West Ham Bournemouth and I think there
was a penalty claim for West Ham and
it was one of those ones where I think
it was penicated for Bournemouth
actually I could be wrong I can't
remember but regardless you know those
ones where you're you're running at full
pace you're going down the wing and
you're trying to make a slighter because
a Sly tackle so he doesn't cross the
ball in yeah but when you when you run
out four person you slide your arm
automatically kind of goes up when
you're sliding so that's how it hit his
hand and that was the deliberation so
obviously all the all like the West
templates like [ __ ]
yeah it's surrounding the referee humble
humble humble what are you gonna do most
of it we're gonna do that handball I
couldn't handle that level of pressure
hand balls stare at the grass that's how
they know they've got you that's how
they know they've got you you're a weak
referee that's how they'll know you've
got you've got to keep your chin up
you've got to keep your chin up James
because they will surround you it's mad
it's mad they put pressure on referee
sometimes you've seen it yeah oh I
couldn't I was like grab it grabbing
shirts
because I have to take it personally
I'll be showing cars from
I'm flying yellows around I don't know
who's who
but anyway
um so obviously they um they went to VAR
to get the man they're behind the scenes
to have a look at this handball to see
if it was handball but like I said
earlier
yeah I I don't want any business I don't
want your parties I don't play for this
they're holding my Manny's earpiece you
deal with it and it's always one of
those ones where every time the referee
um has to deal with the situation he has
to go up field to look at the on the
on-screen situation but the funniest
thing about it is the way these men jog
to the screen yeah they joke like you
know them them white horses are like
Disney movies
that's how they jog because they know
I'm about to change the dynamic of this
whole game and there's nothing any of
you can say to you yeah so the power of
the referee is hilarious yeah because
the ego in his head is like it just it
sweeps me because obviously I watch
football a lot so I see it happen all
the time and the way there's Julius he's
on the fan the way they just Gala yeah
he's on one of these things
it's exactly thumbs up or thumbs down
and there's nothing you man can say to
me bro to be fair like it's it's very
easy to like
um I always think like when you think
about stuff like that I think
I always think like why are they like
that why they're like that but then I'm
like well
what kind of person wants to be a
referee anyway
quick segue
um I really I am really really
interested a lot of people might not be
but personally I am because there's
loads of documentaries about football
football players and blah blah I would
love to see
from a referee or linesman point of view
and I don't know why I just feel like it
would sounds terribly boring for you and
I'm not gonna lie to you yeah but it's
different for you though because I I
watch football yeah yeah and I feel like
if I see it from the perspective of a
referee especially because one we never
hear what they say when they speak to
lions and stuff I feel like if you can
get a deep dive into like certain
situations and certain games I feel like
it would it would be entertaining yeah
yeah more than like an eye opener type
of thing that's what I that's why I
would like to watch it fair play but
yeah for me it would just seem
interesting very interesting it's fair
play it might be interesting I'd be
interested in the emotional breakdown
um when they get home at night and they
hang up their stuff bro and they're just
talking to the camera like I gave I gave
my money I gave Rooney a red car today
yeah I really shouldn't have done it
yeah yeah I don't know if I was right
cool and like oh bro and then like I was
leaving and then some fans spat on my
face
and all the time if let's say Obviously
West Ham for example and they give the
opposition a penalty everyone is
screaming the referees are one cars and
I'm just there in front of 50 000 people
100 just in bright yellow bro you're the
biggest man on the pitch yeah me bro
everyone knows your name
uh uh like
I'm pretty sure they meant cake referees
like friendly level I'm sure I'm sure
they do I'm intrigued I'm sure level but
yeah I'm I'm I would be intrigued to see
like a one-off documentary of like the
life of a referee in like big games
maybe for like um if they did a spin-off
of like a world cup thing and just see
what the what the refugees are but I
don't know man I'll be very interested
in it yeah man I'm glad to see the
statistics of the suicide rates as well
because I'm sure they're of referees
yeah
I'm not gonna lie to you but I'm pretty
sure they're high why because it's
depressing food for the reason that we
just said because you just said 50 000
people to call it me a ranker they don't
even know my first name
I don't think the suicide ratings will
be high I'm not gonna lie to you James
bro because if there were there would be
there'll be processes in place there
would be processes in place counselors
yeah bro yeah I don't think it's not
talking me off this bridge they call me
a wanker my first day is a on my
birthday as just like a Prem level yeah
would be hell oh that's a problem
here yeah you think I'm letting you get
to here
I'll be doing forehead to forehead like
lemon do with the defender they would
nudge you bruv they couldn't they would
Neymar will get it name was obliques
would get wrecked
these men could never said to me like
that bro you will lose
everything I don't think you get that
would be the greatest former match to
watch if you were a referee yeah and it
was like
um PSG versus Barcelona sign and you
just caused a Ruckus oh bro Every Man's
surrounding you and you're just body
blowing everyone yeah 100 squaring up
100. I would love to see yeah because my
um I don't have the stomach for it and I
don't I've got the patience
and all it would take for me in game one
is I think I'm finally here yeah I'm
finally here yeah I do my little white
horse gallop I'm working around like
right this is massive oh I can't believe
I made it yeah yeah yeah kick off
everything gas everything's because
everyone waits for your whistle everyone
waits for your whistles
also Imagine the first whistle being too
quiet because you're a little piece
but then you have to double it oh sorry
what's going on did we stop start or
you're like
no go go and then like what and you're
like you have to go again here [ __ ] and
then just they're like [ __ ] it and you
look at the lines they're just looking
at it
so that's how it starts and then so
that's how we're going we're going we're
going little foul here let's be calm no
yellow cards let's do this do this to
this and all it takes is just like one
bad chord I'm like mate I'm certain yeah
the handbook says that's a yellow
brother the handbook that I read I don't
know about these man that's a yellow so
I'm doing a little yellow thing yeah all
of a sudden
surround and I'm like swear swear and
I'm like hey guys that's right it's
right
all right guys Jesus Christ in Christ
that joke yes yellow yeah and we're
gonna do a yellow but it's all right
yeah it's all right you managed to win
it like
is still winning
you Minister would instead of a warrior
and they're like oh swear yeah yeah
favorites or something I'm upset I'm
thinking okay get get back out there
I'm out there again next thing
these men want a penalty as far as I
know that's not a penalty yeah okay
handbook says no okay BR says definitely
not okay so I'm like all right whistle
um
again these men are here yeah and now
there's pressure on that old facts
there's pressure on me and then they're
just doing all this and I'm like hey hey
and then I'm feeling tugs on my shirt
yeah they untuck my shirt from my shorts
running out he untucks myself
and I'm just tucking it in like looking
around one of your sprays jump on the
floor oh okay see now I'm a bit these
men are actually moving a bit Cricket
yes and I'm like all right guys let's
just yeah yeah let's play on and then
we're going going next free kick bang
that's a free kick I'm not doing yellow
cards but all of a sudden no one comes
over but I'm seeing this I'm seeing this
and then all of a sudden all I'm here is
referees
I'm like raw swear it's only 25 minutes
it's only been 25 minutes literally
you've got I'm doing my job and I'm on
I'm on here yeah and I can the the these
men in the box or whatever they're just
dashing stuff
straws on that and I'm like swear these
[ __ ] picks up bro he's not
actually [ __ ] picks bro next thing
whistle these men are doing up this
again bro I'm giving everything but I'm
waving and whistling I'm with whistling
and waving
here
here pressing me up because he's already
got a yellow yeah yeah he's off yeah
he's livid I'm doing this this yeah
realize him grab his shirt red here and
he's doing this and [ __ ] and I'm I
swear and then I give him a little
that's a little bit back because I'm
trying to be passive yeah I'm trying to
be passive but I'm still a man oh the
vao will clock it [ __ ] you and fire you
oh hey hey hey and then I'll dig in my
back foot yeah give him a little one of
them and he feels it there and he tries
it and I'll rock his room I'll rock his
rib and drop him
bang come over the top bang drop him
that'll be your career done whistle the
floor you man a dickers oh you man a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] job you want to get rushed yeah
oh you would get rough games I won't
make out the stadium 100 you'll find
body parts everywhere I will act bad
until I get in the tunnel
you'll just hear my stars clinking in
there the cleats gone gone because
you'll hear me like yeah and they just
you're done in this whole Space you'd
have to move country you'd have to move
country 100 that is hilarious thank you
for that all right say less that was a
stupid little that's my my my fa career
done um I've got a random trash news for
you uh so let's continue to find it
cool I don't know if you've seen this
pregnant woman to be offered free Vapes
by Lambeth Council
women will be handed free Vapes by South
London Council in a to stop them from
spending so much money on cigarettes
Lambeth Council estimates their new not
their new stop smoking service will
hopefully save parents two thousand a
year uh two thousand pounds a year sorry
money they claim will be otherwise spent
on Tobacco the council said using
e-cigarettes can help women become
smoke-free that's the dumbest thing I've
ever seen that's the dumbest thing I've
ever seen so they're trying to
give them free Vapes to stop them buying
cigarettes pregnant women yeah I didn't
even get to that party
pregnant women free Vapes to stop them
buying cigarettes because they're
wasting money on Tobacco so they could
have more money for their you is
basically what they're saying that's a
waste of taxpayers money I'm not paying
for that that's a huge waste of mind
what are we talking about yeah
walk on in South London there must be a
pandemic yourself oh yeah a top smoker
Smokey pandemic over there
they're trying to be yeah they're trying
to be at the Forefront of progression
yeah that's disgusting because that
doesn't that just doesn't sit well with
me and also I you best you'll find me at
the council pick it in cuss in all these
pregnant Yachts that rock up to claim
that's claim the Vapes yeah every single
One's Gonna hear from me boy because I'm
giving you the Vape I'm gonna cost you
at the same time Rags as soon I'm
holding it and I'll grip it away when
they try and take it look at me look at
me why are you taking this are you thick
how far gone are you bro
next thing you don't even practice
you're not meant to be here yeah there's
gonna be better actually I better see
man in there oh Rags Rags they'd have to
have Security in 2022 you'll see man up
yeah rags and so how can you tell me I'm
not pregnant
run me my triple mango Vape
I ran out last night I need a real fam
run it to me now oh my f isn't it yeah
we were in lambeville aren't we it's
Lambert the catches like everyone else
but run me my vape run me The Vape never
that's the dumbest thing oh it is that's
100 I actually can't believe that that
potentially is going to be a thing yeah
it can't be someone needs to that needs
to make it higher up in the yeah yeah so
they can shine Rishi needs to look at
that and say no just build them once
you're acting yeah just be like joked
I've been here five minutes lock that
off lock that all off because they're
gonna blame me yeah right it's gonna
climb up and they're gonna blame me we
haven't got time or money for that in
fact we've got neither fam we've got the
cost of living crisis a new man of
freeing up Vapes the pregnant yes
inside where are your [ __ ] priorities
Lambeth
for this
the [ __ ] the economy's in the pan bro
and I'm spending my afternoon on the
phone to you telling you telling you not
to give free Vapes to pregnant women I
never thought that's a sentence I'd have
to say um I never thought it's a
sentence I'd have to say here I am but
here I am joking lucky lock it I don't
next time we speak I really hope it's
under better don't make me come down
there
yeah yeah 100 I promise you I'm not
coming down there because you won't yeah
you won't have a job
um to wrap up the episode
um oh you've got a thread today I've got
a little nice little thread
um the thread is
it ain't my business but it bothers me
anyway
that's what the title is as it says this
sounds like something I wrote
I'm obsessed with stuff that's not my
business but it bothers the [ __ ] out of
me okay name something that's that's not
any of your business but bothers you
anyway this is um I found this on
Instagram people stand up as soon as the
plane lands ah bro
and I listen and I know my life yeah
yeah yeah this [ __ ] is here yeah yeah I
can't even get out bro and as soon as
the plane that's up sit the [ __ ] down
bro up seat belt off up because now I
have to get my leg out into the aisle so
I can block you so I can get up and take
my finger and I'm not bro you're not
gonna make me right
I promise you now you're not gonna make
me rush because we're all getting off
anyway so relax bro stuff like that
pisses me the [ __ ] off people ask you to
pray for them on Facebook but not to ask
questions about what happened I need
some details so we ain't so we ain't
wasting big God time on you going court
for a parking ticket
facts right pray for me and my family
pray for me why don't worry bad stuff's
going on pray for us
what's going on don't ask questions just
pray just pray for me
that I need to ask I need the answers
when people argue and that white phone
be in the corners of their mouth
that's that's uh oh that's the worst
that's not that is the worst that to be
fair if I'm arguing with you and I'm
well if I'm seeing the white foam in
your mouth I'm pretty sure it is my
business
that is if I'm close enough for you to
if I'm close enough to you to see the
white foam I'm fairly certain this is my
business I'm pretty sure that's my
business
facts facts um I've only got a few more
when I see kids walking to and from
school by themselves
um so where are your parents
where's your guardian where the [ __ ] is
your guardian I see that sometimes not
even like to and from uh school when I'm
probably a manual walking on road or
whatever and I just see literally Utes
by themselves I'm I look 360 like
where's the closest adult
that looks relatively related to you
because I don't see why you're by
yourself I don't understand I see you
sound I don't see why I don't understand
why you're by yourself I see you you're
a child never wearing coats
facts there was white they don't own a
coat they've got bus up trainers and
they're just lobbing stones and [ __ ]
I also don't want this smoke yeah
cause I'll mind my business I'll kneecap
you yeah I don't want this smoke don't
lob a stone at me or my vehicle yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm in mind my
business yeah facts
um
when my co-worker's boyfriend dropped
her off to the work in a kind of a read
property when my co-worker's boyfriend
drops her off to work in her own car and
then drives off that's embarrassing is
embarrassing that's embarrassing
he needs to run errands today and he
doesn't have a vehicle everyone at work
knows that's her car
so he doesn't even make it in he's just
known as he's just he's got an alias no
one knows his name the boyfriend the
boyfriend
that's right he's just whipping your car
around today
broke and he's got [ __ ] all to do
all the all the errands that's
disgusting exactly first of all that
could I promise you that could never be
me I promise you that could never be me
they couldn't but yeah that was that was
a threat that was a cute little thing
I found obviously I don't usually
contribute to tweets but I found two
tweets this week these are going to be
my tweets of the week right oh maybe
I'll start doing this okay I'm gonna do
a full fret okay my favorite two tweets
of the week I like that let's go let's
roll let's go where's the first one this
one sweeted me okay this one sweet of me
thank God don't cook for him because
he'll cheat on you with the strength he
got from your food
he'll cheat on you with the strength
he's got from your food Bam from the
energy
he sustained from your cooking he's
gonna take it and cheat on you and just
go and [ __ ] that [ __ ] wow wow that's
hilarious to me that is hilarious I
can't I read it I can't imagine the
bitterness of the woman who typed that
facts because she's been there don't be
cook of him because he's gonna take that
energy and cheat on you [ __ ] man that's
hilarious that's hilarious and specific
bro this one suited me
y'all wanted this cuddle weather now
look at you lonely shivering and ashy
ashy
I was expecting that actually
kicking them while they're down
lonely cold and shivering and ashy
that's possible
yeah do you keep doing this tweets I
like it I like it lonely shivering and
ashy I like that bro all right cool
those are my yeah those are my tweets
today so maybe guys yeah I'm gonna start
doing tweets of the week
um just from my favorite [ __ ] because
I'm not on Twitter like that when I see
a gem yeah yeah when I see a gem you
gotta save it [ __ ] funny bro oh that
cheat on you one sweeted me
a weapon formed against
all right cool guys so uh a bit of a
shorter one today yeah short and sweet
first episode of the new student you're
still getting used to the boundaries in
here
um or the lack thereof and um yeah man
as always guys patreon.com
shits and gigs get a bonus episode on
Thursday we'll see you there we're just
going to assume that you're on your way
so we'll see you there on Thursday
thanks
[Music]
foreign